a March of victory for Justin Jones
hundreds rallied in support of the
democratic representative as he made his
way to the Tennessee State house after
being appointed Back to the Sea from
which he was expelled only a few days
earlier
you know we stand together and and we
will fight together
Tennessee law gives law officials the
power to fill vacancies in the state
legislature the Nashville city council
voted unanimously to restore Jones to
office four days after Republicans
stripped him off his seat
the rare vote to expel a member came
days after three adults and three
nine-year-old children were killed in a
school shooting only a few kilometers
from the Capitol building
[Applause]
that led to protesters entering the
State House calling for stricter gun
laws
Jones along with fellow Democrats Justin
Pearson and Gloria Johnson LED chance on
the house floor during the demonstration
the so-called Tennessee 3 all face
expulsion boats but only two men who
were black were barred and not their
white colleague in a move that was
widely criticized as a racist I think
expulsion is one of the most drastic and
extreme actions that can be taken
against a lawmaker and it should only be
used for the most severe actions and
behaviors but these two young men were
expelled and it completely negated the
the wishes of their voters moments after
Pearson could be held in his home City
of Memphis on Wednesday
but is on a system
Plantation politics
Jones's appointment is only temporary
special elections will be held in the
near future to fill both seats for the
remainder of the legislature's term
both say they will run but for now the
expulsions have become a rallying cry
for Democrats campaigning against gun
violence and racial inequality
Sharif Al Jazeera